the way theses consolation of philosophy
ends by introducing and dealing in a
rather novel way with an at that time
already old problem the problem of
divine foreknowledge that is whether God
can know about things that are to come
without thereby destroying human free
will in the process and this is a
classic problem not only in the
philosophy of religion where we're
thinking about conceptions of the divine
and the Divine's relation with the rest
of the universe including human beings
but also in the philosophy of action
where we're thinking about questions
about well what is freedom and our human
beings really free or are they causally
determined in some way and how does
action actually take place no but we
theist has pointed out to him in this by
philosophy that this is not a radically
new problem as a matter of fact it's
been around for a long time as a matter
of fact it's even been around longer
than the sort of monotheistic matrix in
which this this might have been a
particularly pressing issue with the
coming of Christianity into ancient
culture and she points out Cicero who is
a Roman philosopher somebody who's
bringing Greek philosophy and in one of
his works actually in several of his
works brings up this issue of fate or
destiny or Providence and the question
is comes up for the Stoics how can we
actually be free if in fact Providence
governs everything doesn't that take
away free will and the Stoics wanted
that as we say have their cake and eat
it too they want to have both of these
things to be true at the same time Dada
to come up with some sort of account of
how that could be the case and it
becomes an even more pressing issue for
Christian philosophers because the stoic
God at least you know whatever God is or
the divine is isn't
really outside of the universe it's it's
somehow within the university it's a
little murky about how that is but for
you know Judaism Christianity later on
Islam God is understood as this
completely transcendent creator of all
that that is who in some way is there
before it who is all knowing all
powerful all good
perfectly wise arranges everything and
the bigger that we make God in this
respect the more and more other things
seem to get pushed to the margins you
might say including human free will and
this raises a lot of really pressing
puzzles and problems though not the
least of which is we do feel like we
actually make decisions rly but if God
already knows what those decisions are
how much freedom is there in them so
we're going to start here by looking
once again at this notion of Providence
because that's the sort of lens that
that is leading us into it and we go
back over this distinction between
Providence and and faith that we theists
made a fairly interesting and useful
distinction so the Providence is divine
reason so Providence is not something
separate from God
Providence is in a certain respect what
God is because God is God's own reason
it's not like human beings where we may
have a rational faculty but that's not
wholly what we are for God God's
goodness God's unity God's reason is
entirely what God is on the other hand
we have fate which is this planned order
which devolves from or makes happen
within the the world what it is that the
divine reason has has planned that's
what we actually come in contact with
more directly and you can think of it in
these terms the Providence itself is
eternal that is in a certain way it's
either outside of
I'm or it transcends time and
encompasses all time whereas fate the
way he's understanding it fate it is
temporal it happens within time so
Providence includes all things in the
same time the time of eternity and fate
controls individual motions of things at
different times and at different places
so you know fate here is not the same
thing as fate their fate now is not the
same thing
its fate there although it's all bound
together in one gigantic almost
incomprehensible matrix another way that
you could think about this is that
Providence is the plan of the craftsman
so when God is creating the universe God
doesn't just first make a few things and
say alright go to it let me see how this
pans out let me tweak it here let me
tweak it there God is actually doing all
the things that God is going to do as
far as the creative activity at every
single point in time or at least that's
the plan the plan of the craftsman but
then the execution of the plan is
happening sequentially in time at
different points in time at different
places and part of the execution is is
it actually left it's not happening
directly from God
it may be left to natural processes it
may be carried out through the
intermediary of other beings that were
created to help out traditionally those
are called angels it may happen through
the intermediary of human beings and
their decisions and this is where we get
to the really interesting part how the
human beings fit into this it sounds
kind of like if this really is the case
then everybody has a destiny and those
destinies all sort of qohen you know
coincide and coalesce and intersect with
each other and you can't really get away
from that that destiny so if that's the
case how are you actually a free being
this is gonna raise some some really
the problems for us as we're gonna see
this is how we could put the dilemma
when you have a dilemma
you're being presented with two
alternatives and if you you can't pick
both and you can't evade the dilemma so
you have to pick any or you have to pick
B and oftentimes when we pose a dilemma
to somebody we're saying you don't
really like where a is going and you
also don't really like where B is going
so you're kind of as we say screwed
either way
that's what a dilemma often is and this
one seems to be like that doesn't it
because either we've got Providence or
we have human free will and it doesn't
seem like they're compatible now why
does the issue turn on foreknowledge
that's something that before we go into
this dilemma we ought to think a little
bit about what does foreknowledge
actually mean it's literally knowledge
that is of what is yet to come
so knowledge of the future not quite the
same thing as the conception of
prophesying because promising means
saying something about the future so
presumably prophesying would rely on
some sort of foreknowledge and if God
really has everything planned out then
that means that God has foreknowledge
but how can God had foreknowledge of
what we call future contingents of
things that either could be or not be
for example I'm wearing this jacket
today I've got a motivation for doing
that I like to keep the videos
consistent across you know a particular
sequence of videos but I could have worn
a different jacket that was within my
power to choose right that's a purely
contingent thing that I'm wearing this
jacket could it could be that some
events that happened that made it
impossible for me to wear this jacket
perhaps the you know apartment burned
down and the jacket is lost with it
somebody breaks in and steals that Jack
I spill acid upon it and burn a hole in
it you know all these things are are
possible so if they're possible if the
future is not yet seemingly fixed but
could go different ways how does God
know it that's one of the questions
about divine foreknowledge so let's look
at the dilemma now if Providence for
knows all human actions all our thoughts
even our desires from eternity what
follows from that well how can human
beings have free will then if God
already knows that I'm going to choose
to walk this way instead of walk this
way I'm not even gonna walk this way so
I want to show you I'm choosing this to
walk this way right if God knows at that
moment in time that I chose it even
though I didn't know in my head what I
was going to do at that point that I
must have been fated to do it how could
I actually say that I'm free maybe you
know everything is a bunch of brain
states neurons firing in our heads or
something like that you know can
understand the brain is something like a
wetware computer the way that people
like to do in science fictiony things
that would actually kind of fit in with
this idea in that case God is the one
who actually knows the entire system and
since God can see all the neurons in
your head and how they're connected up
god knows what you're going to do at
each moment and God knows this about
everything else in the universe and how
they're gonna react to each other and
interact so we wouldn't have freewill
that would we we might have the illusion
of free will but we wouldn't actually
have freewill
that's one point of the dilemma do we
want to accept that probably not so
let's say we go to the other side
you know if human beings have free well
then that raises some problems too
doesn't it how can there actually be
foreknowledge that if I can choose at
any given point what I'm going to
how can God know about that ahead of
time aren't those events up to the human
being doesn't that make them not
necessary or even uncertain how can God
know at any given point in time whether
I am going to sing a song or dance a jig
or blow my nose or start whistling or
call the dog or just sit here and do
nothing God couldn't know that about
things that don't have free will right
God can know where the little bunny
rabbits gonna jump left or right or eat
the grass or eat the carrot but that's
because that's just you know an animal
without free will when it comes to
beings that actually do have free will
doesn't that introduce something what we
can call a radical indeterminacy things
not being settled into this entire
system it gets worse much of what we do
with our free will is react to other
people's uses of their own free will so
imagine now a system in which we have
not just one thing with freewill making
decisions about what's going to happen
in the future that presumably God's got
to wait around and see we have a whole
bunch of them all reacting to each other
affecting each other whether woody
theist writes this book or doesn't write
this book whether we think about these
issues or not free will so it seems like
we either have to have foreknowledge
coming from providential planning of
everything everything from eternity or
we have freewill and we can't have both
that's the dilemma before he provides
his own fairly long and detailed
explanation about how it's possible to
reconcile divine foreknowledge with
human free will and have them fully be
what they are without any sort of
compromises about any shaving off bits
of them boys Ian's is going to examine
two other what he considers failing
solutions to them to solutions
actually are going to raise other
problems and are not really getting to
the heart of the matter now one thing I
do want to mention here is he talks
about this as being a Gordian knot to
unravel the Gordian knot was a famous
puzzle of antiquity and it actually was
a knot of cords tied together a lot of
people tried to solve it but it was so
massive and there were so many things
involved in it that when you would pull
on one part you were thinking you were
actually unraveling it you'd actually
make the other part tighter and nobody
could figure it out so it's there and it
was in fact solved if you want to call
it that by Alexander the Great who comes
along and they say tonight you must not
be so great if you can't do this knot
puzzle here and he takes the sword and
he cuts it right in half and he says
problems all now is that really solving
the problem it depends on how you
understand that it's certainly one way
of dealing with the problem but we this
doesn't want to do that
Louie theists wants to actually unravel
all of the intellectual problems and
puzzles and paradoxes involved in this
and so he's going to contribute a really
interesting solution of his own perhaps
it's not the only plausible solution but
it's certainly one of them that's up
there when when you look at people who
are trying to think about these sorts of
issues but like I said first he's going
to examine two other proposed solutions
that other people have put forward and
just going to try to show why they don't
actually work one proposed solution that
has in fact had some adherence in the
past is to say that something that will
happen in the future is foreseen by
Providence not because Providence is
doing something but because Providence
is kind of reacting Providence is
passively looking on and seeing what's
going to happen with these sorts of
things not really much of an issue for
st. natural phenomenon that don't
involve free will like you know what
leaf is gonna fall this way or that way
or whether the weather's gonna be of a
certain type that a certain day but it
is an issue for human affairs for the
human world because human beings have
free will and we could represent it like
this you know we think about our
timeline is going from the past of the
future that's our typical conception of
time we have events along the way and
we're always moving towards the the
future you know we can't get back into
the past except perhaps by memory or
something like that the past is fist one
something has happened it's happened and
Providence takes in all of the different
times all these little slices of time
and so if we're thinking about a future
free choice that a person is going to
make and we're going to keep it super
simple here do action eight or do action
B until the person actually makes the
choice which is what it means that free
will to be able to make the choice
between those without something else
determining that choice until somebody
makes that choice we don't know which
one they're going to do after they've
done that choice we can say okay they
did action a they could have done action
B but they didn't do actually so now
that sort of canceled out and we're not
gonna worry about it anymore and
Providence sees the choice going on and
sees the action that results from them
and so because Providence has this kind
of privileged situation as far as what
it can see Providence or God has
foreknowledge of future events it might
even you know if we want to work this
way backwards when you make a new year's
resolution and you know you can either
break it at a whole bunch of different
points or you can persevere to follow
through God would see at every single
point you either breaking it or or
following through it would be sort of
you know a present thing for God but the
reason why
God sees that happening is because you
choose that now what would be wrong with
this it creates a kind of necessity but
it seems like human actions are
necessitating Providence so doesn't that
seem a little bit strange
human beings are necessitating the way
God has to be when God is supposed to be
this this planner who knows everything
who's all-powerful how can we actually
choose in such a way to make God be what
God is because remember providence is
the mind of guys god's reason is god
itself so this doesn't seem to be
workable because if you're allowing
human beings to decide what what god is
that's uh that seems a little sketchy
doesn't it now but we theus also has
another complaint about this sort of
thing as well what kind of knowledge is
this really is this really knowledge
when we talk about what comprises
knowledge we mean that we actually know
something to be the case so if somebody
says is it going to rain tomorrow or is
it going to rain tomorrow the valid
response to that is I don't know or you
can say well I know that the weatherman
says there's a 60% chance but I also
know that weather men's estimates are
often incorrect so let's set it between
40 and 80 percent chance and and I'll
say that I know that but it's just a
probability I don't really know it when
it comes to contingent things
particularly things that are dependent
on human free will can we say that we
truly have knowledge about them if we do
then what can
knowledge could that possibly be louie
theist has philosophy talk about this in
this way if anyone thinks something is
different from what it is not only is it
not knowledge but it's a false opinion
very far from the truth of knowledge so
something is destined to happen in a way
in such a way that its occurrence is not
certain and necessary who could four
know that it is to happen for just as
knowledge is unalloyed by falseness that
which is understood by knowledge
comprehended by knowledge could not be
other than it's actually understood so
when when God according to this
viewpoint sees the free choice he grasps
or hip grass whatever God is the choice
and is supposed to have knowledge about
it but it's not really knowledge of a
free choice it's just knowledge of what
actually happened in a way this is
taking knowledge away from God this may
take a little bit to sink in but it's
worth thinking about knowledge in this
understanding that the we theist is
articulating knowledge needs to be of
the free choice as the free choice as
something contingent but that seems to
be ruled out by the very understanding
of knowledge that we're working with
here so this solution deals with things
it seems to reconcile them by saying
that well you know Providence just sees
with what we've already you know what
we're doing down the line in deciding
and we're in some way because we're
making that choice that's why God grasps
things the way God does that's why it's
part of the divine plan that seems to
make the plan rather capricious doesn't
it it's not much of a plan at all
so that's one big problem the second
solution that buoy is is going to
consider it is really the flip side of
the first and it's a reaction of the
first if you're going to say well you
know given the idea that we're working
with here that some
the events necessitate God's
understanding or God's foresight that's
not really knowledge and that wouldn't
be appropriate you know for what we're
discussing here then we can say well no
God actually does have knowledge in the
full sense God knows exactly what's
going on from all eternity for knowledge
really is knowledge and it binds human
thoughts and actions to only going one
particular way well if that's the case
then we're back and square - you might
say more square one depending on which
side of the dilemma you're looking at
and we don't have free will now if
that's the case there are some other
problems that come up
notice what Boethius is doing here he's
saying look we believe this and and this
makes sense over here but if we adopt
this point of view this stuff we have to
throw it all out so that can't possibly
be correct
what are these considerations he's got
two that he brings up that are
particularly trenchant one is how can
there actually be any sort of reward for
a virtue and punishment for vice if
that's the case how is it that
providence which is supposed to give
good things as a reward to good people
including to those who actually turn to
goodness and development goodness and
give bad things to bad people as their
punishment that's the understanding of
Providence that he's working with how
can that possibly be the case because it
seems like the people who actually
develop virtues who act in good ways who
do the right thing they don't really
have a choice about it they're fated to
do so so why are they deserving of
anything if that's the case isn't it
kind of unfair to give them a reward for
what they would do anyway likewise the
people who do bad the people who are
vicious who do you know hurtful hateful
things to other people or destroy
themselves or you know blaspheme or
whatever it is the people who are
vicious why can it be okay for
Providence to punish them if they didn't
have any choice in the matter if they
couldn't have
they done otherwise he's not just saying
that they don't have merit or demerit
he's saying that that would make
Providence itself unfair which would
make Providence in a certain way in
Providence at least imprudent it
wouldn't be a lot of things correctly
because it would be giving people things
they don't deserve another big issue if
this is really the case if everything is
totally faded then what good would there
possibly be in hoping hope is something
that we do about something that is not
yet here
it's a future-oriented kind of you could
call it a motion or effect or act on our
part but it wouldn't make sense to hope
about anything I also wouldn't make any
sense to despair I suppose he doesn't
worry about that so much everything is
just going to be as it is including your
own choices it's sort of like somebody
who says you know I know that this is
the right thing over here and I hope
that I do the right thing but I don't
know that I will because I don't really
have any choice in the matter it's just
gonna happen the way it's gonna happen
likewise we can't really say anything
about hoping about other people it
doesn't make sense it doesn't even make
sense to hope in in God or Providence
also prayer couldn't possibly make sense
because what is the point of a lot of
Prayer praying is in in large respect
asking God for something to go in one
way or another of course there's other
types of prayers well Thanksgiving for
example confession all that sort of
stuff
but he's talking about prayer as in
beseeching God to help us out if you
think about you know paradigmatic
prayers you know whether they be you
know the Greek hymns to the various gods
or the the you know the Lord's Prayer
they our Father that Christians have or
you know various other prayers quite
often they're saying God won't you do
this instead of doing that and if
thing is totally faded all the way down
to individual human actions and choices
it wouldn't make sense for example to
pray about somebody who is making bad
choices Lord won't you give them some
insight or won't you steer them the
right way or bring them back to you know
some sort of sense of conscience or a
contrition that wouldn't make any sense
either that's gonna happen or it's not
gonna happen you're you're praying
doesn't add anything to it so if this is
really the case then what does that do
to traditional conceptions of the human
relationship to God it pretty much
nullifies them doesn't it and it also
might induce a kind of disparity way
theists says that if this is really the
case then we really do have nothing to
hope for because we're so far away from
God and Providence then we have no way
to actually get any closer these are
part of how we get closer the solution
that Boethius is going to propose to us
or philosophy rather is going to propose
to buoy theists who that is transmitting
it to us is one that may require you to
do a bit of stretching in your thinking
and he understands that that's going to
be the case because one of the issues
involved in the way this problem has
been set up is we've made some
assumptions some very natural
assumptions for human beings to make
because of the kind of beings that we
are the kind of experience of time that
we have which don't really apply quite
so well to the universe to Eternity and
to the divine so if you find yourself
having trouble you know fam fathoming
this or accepting it that's okay it's
not the sort of thing where you just set
up the the premises and the conclusion
of automatically follows and boy you
just see it like that sort of like
solving a math problem rather you you
have to sort of think your way into this
he is going to start by talking about
knowledge itself and thinking about the
kinds of knowledge that we have he's
gonna talk about degrees of knowledge
and these are going to correspond to
different faculties different parts of
the human being and knowledge we often
get mistaken by thinking that knowledge
just depends on the object of knowledge
what it is that's being known so to know
a ball for example and put it in our
hand knowing that ball means knowing
everything about the ball where it came
from what's made of how it feels how it
bounces or doesn't bounce all those
sorts of things but if we think about it
a little bit more deeply we realize that
knowledge it actually depends on
something else it depends on the ability
to know of the knower it depends on what
they're using to get to know that he's
going to talk in terms of faculties but
if you wanted other examples of this you
could think for example about when we
make a distinction between knowing
somebody by acquaintance and by spending
time with them and just knowing their
their you know statistics their dossier
their permanent record file right it's
not quite the same thing is it those are
not the same kind of knowledge and we
would say that the other person who
actually has spent time with and has
developed a level of intimacy with the
other person knows them better than the
person who's got the rap sheet well it
can work that way with our faculties as
well
we have sense perception you can see
things you can hear things you can taste
them you can you can touch them then we
have the imagination and the imagination
for boëthius isn't just you know this
Faculty of putting images in our head
and thinking about things creatively
it's also what brings together the the
sense perceptions so that we can grasp
for example shape you know you don't
actually see shapes when you see our
colors and you don't actually you know
feel the exact same thing perception
wise
as what you're seeing the imagination
puts them together another word for this
is what we call common sense and then we
have reason this is what sets us apart
from the animals and other beings can
have imagination and they react to
things so dog sees you know a rabbit and
chases after the rabbit the rabbit sees
the carriage chases after the carrot and
you know pretty soon we gain a whole
progression of things could something
eat a dog chasing the dog we actually
are able to step back and think about it
we can work discursively we can put
things on a chalk board that's all a
function of reason reason deals with
universals not just particulars then
there's a higher faculty and you can
translate this as intelligence intellect
understanding there's different ways of
translating the same basic idea but the
idea is that there's a higher not really
discursive but more straightforward way
of grasping things it goes right to the
heart of the matter and we don't want to
associate this necessarily like
intuition or feeling because this isn't
talking about that much of our
intuitions are really just at the level
of imagination but we do have something
like this not that developed in human
beings but in God that's the way God
knows things God doesn't know things for
sense perception by you know opening his
eyes and looking around oh I see you
down there doing bad things I see you
doing good things that's not the way it
works God doesn't have imagination God
doesn't even you know have reason in the
same sense that we do it's sort of a
hyper reason God is intellect that is
the kind of thing that God actually is
God is God's act of knowing you might
say and here's where we go wrong human
reason tries to confine God's intellect
God's intelligence God's understanding
to what human reason can grasp so it's
sort of like saying unless you can fit
into my NER
categories whatever you have to say is
invalid and you know what if imagination
was to say that to reason
what if imagination and sense were to
say to reason there's no such thing as
Universal there's no such thing as you
know or there's just or so there's no
hoarseness there's no essence of the
species there's nothing that actually
connects all these things together
reason would say you just don't get it
do you
you're not capable of grasping what it
is that I can grasp what God's intellect
it works a little bit like that as far
as their own reasoning processes except
that we're able to understand God to a
certain extent so how should we think
about this that set got this some
diagram here the key thing is that God
knows eternally and we often tend to
picture eternity as if it is just part
of time remember we have this temporal
you know this time arrow we start out
and what's actually at present but is
going to turn into the past you can look
at it as a everything is flowing this
way or you can look at it as
everything's going this way right
depending on your point of view but we
have all these little slices and at any
given point in time we're at you know at
this point and we've got past behind us
and we've got future ahead of us and by
the time that we actually like you know
put the axe there we're already over
here we're already over there we're
moving along this thing we don't own our
past because we don't carry it with us
except perhaps in our memories and the
traces upon us we certainly don't own
our future because that's yet to come
for us that's the way we experience time
that's the way that reason understands
temporal events and it's great I mean it
enables us to do really super cool
things you know the very fact that we
can put clocks in place means that
ultimately we can have computers and
lead to you know wonderful digital
cameras that can record videos you know
how long this video is and we have this
amazing capacity to master time but
that's not the medium in which god no
things so if we're going by time and
we're not thinking in terms of eternity
we're gonna be missing out eternity can
be understood as one vast present that
comprises and unfolds and binds together
all of these times so that they're all
present at the same time for eternity
you might say man I can't I can't really
conceive of that that that boggles my
mind well it boggles reason it doesn't
boggle intellect and the fact that it
does you know it's hard for us to think
is because our intellects are really not
very strong they're not the divine
intellect but the divine intellect
according to previous is able to take in
it's not even able to take in it does
take you and that's what God does God
sees all of time as an eternal present
with all of these times present at the
same time it sounds a little paradoxical
when I put it that way doesn't it now
when we get to the issue of for
knowledge and free ads so a human free
act from the perspective of a given
point in time it's not known what that
free act is going to be that's what it
means for us for it to be a free act
that we can't say whether it's going to
go or not
I'm planning on leaving you know on the
on you know a certain date and time with
my wife to drive to the Midwest to see
our family and you know we'll you know
we made we we've got a plan to stay in a
certain hotel on the way that may happen
that may not happen maybe I take the
wrong path and we end up in North
Carolina instead of in the Midwest
that's a that's a contingent possibility
right crazier things would happen than
that maybe we get a wild hair and we say
forget family Christmas we're just gonna
drive all the way to California that's a
possibility too right
I can say at this point in time that's
not what my plans are but can I say with
absolute certainty a possibility that
that's the case
I can't know once I get there and I
actually make that decision and you know
where we're driving we get on 280 and
you know we see a road that would take a
south and we say no I'm gonna keep on
going out 80 keep going west once we've
decided that that's now in the past
that's been decided there is a kind of
necessity to it but it's not because
it's a free act it's not necessary in
its nature it didn't have to be that way
that's what it is for it to be a free
yeah it's contingent from the
perspective of God in the eternal
present that choice has already happened
or in fact it's wrong to save it it's
already happened it's happening at the
same time as all of the other choices
are happening there is no time in
eternity that can pass all the times
simply are and so there is a kind of
necessity to it but it's not the kind of
necessity this is where we get to the
solution it's not the kind of necessity
that makes that free Act no longer a
free act as a matter of fact it's a
necessity of it being a free act that
was decided at that point in time or
rather is decided at that point in time
which is not future for God but is
rather part of the eternal present it's
just as much part of the eternal present
as the ancient history of the past long
before either you know I was conceived
of or before my ancestors you know going
back 40 generations were and it's just
as real for God just as present for God
as the ultimate you know collapse of the
universe which perhaps may happen we
don't know would be as well all of that
would be equally present for God so what
this means is God does in fact for a No
and has encompassed within this
providential ordering human free acts
and human free acts truly are free acts
they're able to go off this way or go
this way but the plan has already
included these going on because the plan
has existed or exists rather in eternity